okay folks uh welcome to legislative
Administration uh been a long hot summer
and time to do some work uh can we start
please Al to of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for all thank
you very
much uh some housekeeping duties first
um we have a new
member representative sers um has uh
taken the place of uh representative
Osborne
for all time um took a step up thank you
very much for serving uh second
committee right so transfer ation and
legi admin great thank you very much um
also have a a new um occurrence um if
representative turkot wants to take a
minute I promised a minute or two sure
thank you chair and thank you community
members uh Alan turkot is now known as
Allison
turkot
woohoo welcome um Allison turkot um you
rep turot to me so that's how we'll
stand um we have four bills on the
agenda today uh as written um we are
going to take up one of them and we will
recess to another date for the other
three um Mr chair I wonder if uh the
Democrats are caucusing and
representative Horgan and I didn't know
it some missing yeah cuz I don't know I
have no idea no one no one me mentioned
it to me we were starting we're
scheduled for 1:00 we're going to start
for 1:00 and I I promise you this is not
going to be an
issue yeah um so we have um we have one
uh the the bill that we plan on taking
up
today
is I've lost the number no this one
um it is Senate Bill 28 um relative to
the portrait in the likeness of Rogers
Johnson and state
house um and I'll explain why we will be
recessing the other three to a later
date um after we handled this um for
Senate Bill 28 um I would
recognize representative xen for a
motion uh yes I move
itl uh repen moves itl on Senate Bill 28
do I have a second I'll second it
seconded by um represent I always call
you Nikki um okay that's do we already
have it on here no no no um
representative mcarter um seconds uh I
would open up to any discussion
represent machine do you want to speak
to your motion uh yes so um I moved itl
um as many of you know that um this bill
was put in the budget that we recently
passed in May so there's really no
reason to pass this
legislation um I'm seeing some puzzle
looks so maybe there are some that
didn't realize that uh we um when we
received this bill and um and voted to
retain it um there were a number of
unanswered questions uh one of those
items was that uh we weren't sure
whether our acceptance of that bill
violated any of the
um any of the
historical uh committee requirements um
there are there are listed in the RSA
for the establishment of the historical
committee um criteria that um they
mentioned one of their duties is to
create criteria to accept um portraits
and we had never seen that CR criteria
so the concern was that we didn't want
to accept the bill without knowing
whether we would be violating any of
those criteria seemed logical to me uh
apparently those that were working on
the uh the budget um from the Senate
side had less concern about the criteria
of the historical committee and uh they
just went ahead and um and unbeknownst
to us put the bill and in its entirety
inside the budget um added the funding
so um it rendered our concerns moot at
that point so um with no nowhere else
for us to go it would seem illogical to
do anything except itl uh this
bill any problems uh further further
hargan I just veried you said was
correct and they actually the only thing
the Senate and then we changed we
accepted the in the conference committee
was uh to put the RSA that uh
establishes a joint historical committee
so you're so you're entirely right I
mean I there you go once one in a row
actually actually to remember Roger
Johnson who I believe was the first
African-American in the Hampshire house
I know my um one close close to it but
um this had nothing to do with uh with
who Rogers Johnson was or or anything
about it it was purely on the uh process
and the procedure um but I appreciate
your uh your comments he definitely
definitely deserves a portrait I vaguely
remember from when my father served in
the
legislature uh you know almost half a
century ago so right he still remembered
good um so as far as we're concerned uh
it's taken care of um uh
honorable uh Johnson will be getting his
portrait has already been accepted I
Believe by the historical committee and
uh and so we can move on and and uh I
think um itl Senate Bill 28 um with that
I'll ask the clerk to call a
rooll thank you very much uh on the
motion of
itl uh Vice chair Shen
yes rep sers yes
here uh clerk votes yes re Pearson not
here re mcarter yes re
Tierney
yes uh rep Schultz in for Janet
wall
yes uh rep nutting Wong yes and
yes uh rep Richards not here rep
conin
yes uh rep Dolan not here rep Montiel
not here and rep Horgan and for rep
payer um I vote uh yes on the
yes
11 y zero Nays I don't know if we want
it no can't okay Bill she was not in
passes okay thank you uh Senate Bill uh
will go to the floor with a
recommendation from legislative
Administration as itl uh 11 y zero nay
um we can close Senate Bill 28 consent
thanks um can it not do cons you know
I'm
not is there a consent calendar on
retain
bills yes there's no reason is there any
objection to consent on
this none from me that's fine
y it's funny how
you when you do things so infrequently
and you're only doing it every couple
years I just had to stop and think
whether consent actually existed on
these I don't I don't recall we had
another issue earlier that we were
trying to figure out um and none of us
had remembered it ever happening before
so it it takes a while the little
chipmunks have to start running in the
wheel again I
think at any rate um so that's uh Senate
Bill 28 and that's probably our most um
um prod productive piece of work today
um I feel a little guilty for having
everyone come to conquer um on the on
the premise that we would be working on
four bills um but we're unprepared for
actually working on the remaining three
um one of
them has a um an
amendment that uh is in and has been
filed with OS but we don't have that
Amendment
um so that's that handles that one um
and that would be um Senate
Bill
301 um Senate bill I mean Senate Bill 84
has been um requested by our leadership
um to hang on to because it relates to
work being ongoing with um the um the
committee on commissions and uh that we
have the special committee on committees
and commissions um and so that they're
asking us to uh put off action on that
bill just on the chance that there's
something that needs to go into that
bill as an amendment so we can't work on
that and the third one um is House Bill
157 that we retained that uh deals with
um The Joint Committee on legislative
facilities and sexual harassment
policies um and that one too
um was being um hopefully a subcommittee
set up by uh representative Pearson who
you'll see is not sitting in that seat
um right now um and we are waiting to
see um the amendment that um that
subcommittee when it when it meets will
come up with
so we're we're out of work um so at the
moment um I apologize for uh for getting
everybody to conquered I thought we
would uh we were in great shape but then
it um through some lug nuts fell off the
wheel and and there's not much we can do
um I will ask however if there are times
um in the next two weeks that uh that
someone can come can let us know whether
your availability over the next couple
weeks if there's a problem in there um
so that we can get as much participation
as we can um having said that I guess I
want to thank the uh substitutes for uh
for participating and uh and I want to
uh publicly congratulate our our newest
member of legislative
Administration who's maybe asleep at the
moment um so I with if anyone has
anything else to add um otherwise I will
uh simply call for
again